Alhamdulillah as you know mashallah one
of the audience wants to take the
shahada. Alhamdulillah please welcome
him on stage so that doctor can
inshallah introduce him to
[Applause]
Islam as a question. He's the same
brother who was asking the question a
few minutes ago to Dr. Sab inshallah.
You can come here.
Brother, do you believe that there's one
God?
Do you believe that there is one God?
Yes, I do. Yes, I do. Do you believe
Jesus is God or Jesus is a messenger of
God? He's a messenger of God. Of course.
Do you believe that Prophet Muhammad is
the messenger of God? Yes. Mashallah.
These two are the minimum two things you
require for anyone to accept Islam.
Number one, that there is no god worthy
of worship except Allah. And number two,
that prophet Muhammad is the messenger
of Allah. Brother, is anyone forcing you
to accept Islam? No. Are you doing it
out of your own free will? Yeah. Mash.
I'll say it in Arabic and we can repeat
it. It's okay.
Ashu. Ashu. Allah. Allah.
Illahill.
Muhammad Muhammad Abdul Abdulu
I bear witness I bear witness that that
there is no god there is no god but
Allah but Allah and I bear witness and I
bear witness that prophet Muhammad that
prophet Muhammad is the messenger is the
messenger and servant of Allah and
servant of Allah and a servant of Allah
Allahbar tagbah
Allahbar
[Music]
go you have name you would like to
choose say to the to this yesterday tell
us what name you'd like
[Applause]
for himself. I pray to Allah subhana wa
tala that may he give him the best in
this and may he guide his family members
and his friends to the true path of
Islam inshallah.